do you have a story  and then think I'm going to create that  visual imagery around that story or do  you have a for example a little black  book of these out there ideas and think  I'm gonna find a way to fit that into a  story no I try to be the other way  around I try to be all about story  um  and then as I'm writing  create  visuals or situations that I actually  don't know how to do and I try to take  my director's hat off when I'm writing  and write things that I I then come to  as a director and I I said I have no  idea how to do this I have no idea what  this will look like how to visualize it  because that's when you know you're  challenging yourself and it's through  that challenge  you then put together a great team of  people and through that challenge you  find something that you haven't done  before you find something fresh and  different and that's really the fun part  of filmmaking that challenge